le chat était était sur sa sur sa route
et oui on se rappelle que Douda on
voyait avant envoyer du G6 F5 à un
moment donné qu'on n'est pas trop aimé
mais c'était cette position en cavalier
FC son cavalier à 6 on l'avait aussi eu
ce qui était parti faire un peu les
bordures pour revenir
parti en bordure pour les fans de Tintin
peut-être H4 c'était le coup je sais
plus
il y avait eu du H4 mais je sais plus
quand en tout cas la tube parce que faut
prendre cavalier prend une dame prend le
cheval est touché
ça peut toucher
c'est toujours les mêmes positions ça
semble proche d'égal mais de les plans
quand même des pièces un petit peu mieux
placées
[Musique]
pas grand chose mais bon tu es un peu
mieux agencé le fou aussi qui est cercle
mauvais fou mais en fait qui tape et
quand tu fais les expansions à l'aide
dame ça peut être bien je suis un grand
fan moi de ces positions avec les Blancs
c'est pas trop risqué
quand même
surtout avec les noirs avec les Blancs
je suis très heureux je bouge un peu mes
pieds
tu cliques un peu tes chevaux tu cliques
un peu des trucs à gauche à droite tu
cliques un peu des tours
tu cliques un peu des pions des deux
côtés je sais pas tu cliques en fait
tu cliques droites à gauche qui est
surpris et ça c'est vu visuellement à
son à son visage dès l'ouverture cavalue
3 alors là il peut y avoir du rebond
alors il peut y avoir soit des fous
prends des 6 cavalier F5 parfois bon
rare mais peu exister ou du cavalier G4
cavalier E5 aussi pour revenir ou même
parfois des cavaliers G4 et après des
des trucs qui arrivent vers le roi quoi
tu vois tu peux combiner avec des tours
pro E7 mais bon là c'est pas c'est pas
possible attention B3 plutôt bien joué
Fab on prend le le contrôle de la case
c'est quoi trop de lui demander est-ce
que Baki a joué aujourd'hui alors Bakin
ne jouait pas aujourd'hui
qui se repose aujourd'hui parce qu'on
devait tourner avec lui les vidéos du
rôle tout 2016 on va quand même rappeler
un petit peu les bases non je sais pas
il a il a c'était prévu qu'il joue trois
parties il a joué les trois premières
et je sais pas comment c'est c'est
comporter son son équipe en Bundesliga à
autrichienne ou du coup il y avait que
Baki qui nous intéresse quoi ok oui
il a pris des très heureux alors en plus
il est heureux parce que bah qui a pris
5,6 points ah donc ça fait 6 donc ça
fait 6 comme il le rejoue pas et oui
c'est terminé et malin marlou
on prend et Punto comme ça c'est pris
instantanément comme il disait pourtant
le 06 fait plaisir bon le 05 aussi c'est
terrible c'était à 0,4 tu as plus de
rejouer bon sinon tu as gâché 04 ah bah
oui là c'est là ça va pas rejouer hein
je t'annonce que là où
donc ce fou qui vient E5 il vient
utiliser la case Fab et peut-être à tout
moment des ça peut ça peut sauter
c'est pas ah c'est des belles positions
ça a joué Fab un plaisir
plusieurs
et pas que
ça peut les toiles d'araignées là ces
deux Spiderman
ça peut s'accrocher et c'est Spider-Man
il y a des Spiderman des Venom non il
s'appelle comment le Spider-Man
noir
il est un peu dark mais il est même plus
fort que le Spider-Man normal non
[Musique]
en tout cas ça ça peut sauter à gauche à
droite
mais tu vois genre des fois tu peux
avoir des trucs genre
tu vois des toiles d'araignées après qui
partent je suis sacrifie là et après tu
voilà ça passera pas
alors barquette en Turquie il entraîne
les jeunes au championnat d'Europe enfin
si c'est pour mettre des fake news ça va
être bandaf superconcellation
malheureusement
bah qui est pas en Turquie il vient chez
moi demain donc
ça va être compliqué d'être en Turquie
pour entraîner les jeunes au
championnats d'Europe voilà c'est ouais
il prend des photos sur Twitter avec son
équipe c'est sur le site de la FFE enfin
bon demande-moi à moi en fait pourquoi
tu parles de sites de la FFE frérot
peut-être qu'il fait des trucs à
distance ou que la FFE dit n'importe
quoi je sais pas mais là il était en
Autriche il est en Autriche il est en
Autriche et demain il est chez moi donc
je suis quand même un petit peu au
courant il dort sur le canapé avec Micha
important ah oui c'est pour ouais
attention quand même Super Constellation
il y a des gens qui ont été ban de
YouTube ou de Twitter pour moi que ça
fake news c'est quand même embêtant
il va attendre que elon Elon Musk
rachète
twitch pour être sauvé voilà
il est plus pour la liberté de parole
plus que par la fake news en fait là en
tout cas c'est de la fake news pure et
dure c'est de la fake news pure et dure
ignal Sarine quoi alors peut-être que
Baki est en Serbie en fait c'est pour ça
que ça rit ne marche sur l'eau
il aura envoyé son double
le Back idark en Autriche
en tout cas il réfléchit là Sarine mais
il sait pas trop quoi faire ouais mais
bon enfin pourquoi tu veux pas
en fait je sais pas quoi jouer avec les
Noirs c'est terrible bah tout va à peu
près
[Musique]
ouais ça joue pas mal côté
sceau qui met une petite pression là il
est dans ses positions ouais c'est après
tu veux un truc tu peux vouloir C4 c'est
5 B4 A4 B5 c'est fort ça comme plan puis
on avance à fond du London après tu fais
un petit H3 peut-être tu reviens tu mets
ta tour en B1 tu pousses ou tu peux
jouer avec Cache Cache 5 aussi c'est tu
as le jeu des deux côtés non mais sous
d'autres ravi il se passe absolument
rien il est pas en danger
il doit très bien bah il est mieux
autant il met la pression il doit être
très très très très très heureux Wesley
ça ronronne quoi
après on a vu aujourd'hui du côté de
Bercy Fabien la surprise rune qui s'est
imposé contre le favori Novak Djokovic
est-ce que NiAl pourrait s'inspirer du
jeune joueur danois
c'est vrai que tu vois je n'entendais
pas avant le match qui attendait pas
mais il a très bien joué une très très
gros match tu joueurs danois non mais je
joue pas mal qui vient te voilà rebondir
un petit peu sur notre conversation
d'hier Fab
mais tenter de te montrer que cette
nouvelle génération des tout jeune peut
venir peut-être renverser
la table
on va voir en tout cas le fou qui est
bien E5 est égal Sarine là qui prend
beaucoup trop de temps Fabien sur ce
coup
ouais bon
attention quand même parce que là à
force de réfléchir je sais pas ce qui va
nous pondre mais pas grand chose à mon
avis
c'est pas quoi faire là c'est peut-être
une position dans lequel il est pas très
à l'aise
qui avait déjà joué en lui contre NiAl
qui l'a rencontré en tout cas qui me
disait quand je l'ai eu ce matin penser
que soit allait gagner assez facilement
aussi
pour même le niveau 2007 il le pas il
lui paraît faible
du coup il était très étonné qu'ils sont
finales il m'a dit oui bon il a battu
séviant et bon c'est bien aussi c'est
pas très fort non plus pour 2007 et le I
et guéri et guéri il est un peu plus
étonné mais après guéri qui s'est un
petit peu battu tout seul j'ai envie de
dire ici il est un peu des jouets
puisqu'il dominait nettement
toujours Fabien être faire attention à
ces coups comme F600 ça a affaiblit des
cases attention
[Musique]
il n'a pas lieu bah tu fais quoi est-ce
que tu prends des 6 pour cavalier F5 ou
est-ce que tu te dis je garde les fous
oh non quand même moi c'est vrai que si
le bouffer il faudra le prendre ouais
mais tu reprendras de H c'est peut-être
que du coup tu es content parce que tu
auras un peu de bah je sais pas en fait
ça c'est du détail en fait normalement
matériel et bon après prise d'essaye il
doit prendre de quoi de la dame si tu
prends du fossilia qui est qu'on est
cinq et fromage de
on reprend à me prendre des 5 tu vois tu
peux essayer de pêcher
un C4 et je sais pas trop bon déjà
première option de toute façon
tu vas être obligé de faire [ __ ]
mais bon
c'est un peu mieux
et ça c'est déjà avantage on peut
montrer la ligne parce que tu as un
petit centre
c'est quoi trop dit non
ok mais peut-être pas c'est quoi trop
peut-être
les cavaliers F4 t'empêche d'ammage 5 tu
auras tout H4 tu vas faire tout avant
c'était une option c'est un petit truc
sympathique
passer deux options équivalentes qui C7
ouh là là ça fait ouais non c'est trop
ça peut pas aller ça cavalier à 6 qui
est ici 7 cavalier E6 F6 cavalier C7 j'y
crois pas trop Fab
c'est un beau dessin de NFC en même
temps ça peut faire une belle NFC
à part ça
si on parle d'échec
[Musique]
c'est un peu trop de coup de chevaux
quoi
de valses
avec les Blancs peut-être
H4 aussi
[Musique]
ça se passe pas trop la tête
c'est peut-être le mieux en fait parce
que tous deux le jour où tu fais tout
rein t'interdiras cavalier 4 tu auras pu
en prendre si on prend qui et prend des
cinq d'imprends des 5 ans 4
en même temps on l'a déjà
mais pas quand tu fais ces 5
tu auras pas quand même
ouais bon tu es très bien là
je crois trop dame j'ai 6
c'est tellement facile ça se joue les
yeux fermés il plaisent with close dies
Fabien
Joseph
en fait
après objectivement je pense que l'ordi
flottante en tout cas contre un humain
mais
ça a l'air tellement dur à jouer
et en plus c'est tellement la position
que tu veux pas avoir contre Wesley il
peut rien lui arriver là Wesley mais je
souffre en silence
[Musique]
tu peux pas vraiment faire de gaffe avec
les Noirs non plus mais bon le truc
c'est que
tu as pas trop d'activité en fait
faut vraiment avoir du courage pour
jouer la pétrole
c'est pas une mauvaise ouverture en soi
c'est hyper solide mais waouh ça donne
tellement pas envie
ouais bon après enfin là c'est la
version fu F5 je sais pas qui se met à
jouer récemment mais comme la journée
pour les trois fous des 6 ça va très
bien
en tout cas cette version là elle donne
pas envie
je sais pas si toi il te donne envie
mais moi j'aimerais pas avoir ses
positions là sans arrêt
H4 H5 selon parler ça pion qui avance
c'est pas très fun
tu te fais chier avec les noirs
là tu te fais chier une force non
tellement écoeuré de la vie quoi
mais on va essayer d'être tellement
heureux j'ai enfin une position
intéressante du jeu d'échec finalement
une semaine que j'essaie d'avoir cette
position d'ailleurs j'espère qu'il me
rejoint la même ouverture à la partie
retour
ça nous promet une finale on balance
beaucoup mieux que le 960 avec ses
pièces placées bizarrement il y a
beaucoup d'autres tactiques dans ce jeu
au complexe
ici les mêmes difficiles de trouver une
gaffe pour les blancs
alors oui les blancs pourraient jouer
dame F5 mais les Noirs la mangeraient
par cavalier des six bref
peut-être un petit H6 un jour peut-être
du cavalier H4 pour aller vers F5
mais alors la jauge n'aime pas du tout à
cause du coup le plus logique d'un af7
pour juste aller bouffer le truc
mais attention parce que tu m'asses pas
rendre le prendre il y aurait peut-être
du C5 et il y a ton cavalier qui est mal
donc bon
tu penses qu'il a rejoue ou pas
on sait pas trop ce qu'il est en tête ça
depuis le début
il a joué des
siciliennes il se prenait des Rosso
limos à la gavée il a fait E4 qui est
ici et à la fin il a fait 4,5 normal et
là je crois que c'est la première
pétrole qu'on lui voit jouer alors après
quand c'est bien je sais pas trop ce qui
se jouait enfin tu on suivait un peu du
coin de l'oeil mais c'est peut-être sa
première pétrole du tournoi quoi non il
a joué le dame F7
peut-être que ce H5 marchait pas trop
ouais c'est un peu logique mais
qui est dégoûté d'abord
je recule quoi je retourne à H2 tant pis
après il menace rien quand même parce
que enfin réellement dame prend c'est ça
et puis peut-être il fait juste fou HD4
enfin tant pis et sur H6 bah j'imagine
qu'il veut juste
g65 et
je crois qu'il y a 5 justement pour pour
attaquer encore H6
américain
ça suit un peu la côte américaine quand
même Fab après un début de partie oui
caracoller
dans maîtrise
totale
d'un petit coup de pion
il s'est trop aventure en attaque en
fait il joue contre nature bah c'est tu
vois c'est le premier coup de la partie
où il dépasse son campement
et là il envoie un pion qui peut pas
reculer donc là automatique comme le
cavalier
et là et là voilà H4 ça aurait été son
coup en fait s'il pouvait
pour revenir vers H3 en fait
et là il est parti trop il est parti
trop loin dans le dans le camp noir
peut-être il faut proposer nul déjà
Fabien côté Wesley
oui très bon choix petite nul qui te
permet de d'aller un petit peu souffler
en salle de repos ça te laisse en plus
40 minutes de pause Fab ici
ah ce serait beau c'est un petit 40
minutes de pause ici pour pour Wesley
non
et ça c'est ça alors moi tu te reposes à
fond
c'est déjà bien
faut pas qu'il oublie sa stratégie faire
faire des petites nulles tranquille quoi
faut pas qu'il s'oblige à jouer offensif
si il a pas envie il faut pas jouer à
contrecoeur il fait à 4 ouais bon tu vas
dépasser la 5e rangée de l'autre côté tu
vas perdre tes deux pions en fait c'est
attention quand même Wesley par un petit
peu peut-être trop à la pêche
en tout cas pour le moment il y a pas
d'improche 5 on va remonter pourquoi
c'est 5 attaque le cavalier qui doit se
déplacer et c'est le deuxième cavalier
dans le dans le viseur du fou qui se
fait sniper
et donc l'option A4
qui avance mais si le cavalier C7 s'en
va il y aura une vraie menace attention
[Musique]
c'est des petits détails Fab mais ce
sont des détails cruciaux importants
et donc il veut venir se diriger vers F5
et venir peut-être faire une prise à
deux c'est un peu du catch quoi et
revenir avec la dame en F5 et venir
enfin défendre le pion mécaniquement HCO
fantastique sont tactiques exactement
donc attention
attention et H6 ça peut être aussi une
menace la tente dans la position Fabien
un peut-être un jour ça va partir comme
ça pour détruire la structure et si G6
de moins forts pour des raisons
tactiques ce serait un gros problème
5,54 contre 5 minutes le temps peut
avoir son importance ici Fabien même si
on a vu que ça Rin pouvait jouer vite
quand même
il sait cliquer
numéro 3 mondial en blitz sur sur
chaise.com c'est quand même c'est quand
même pas rien Fabien c'est le gotha
bleue
donc même en cas de hypnot ça va alors
l'ordinateur propose cavalio 4 mais je
pense que il refuse de jouer à cause de
fou prendre dame prank puis on prend
pion prend cavalier prend des 5 t'en
reprend des 5 tours
[Musique]
côté noir si on bloque le pion sur des 4
je pense que oui
si tu fais des cinq et que tu protèges
le truc c'est fini mais là tu y arrives
peut-être on peut mais un joueur que
visuellement c'est hyper dur de prendre
de faire le choix de faire cavalier 4
ce que faut comprendre tu récupères H5
que le mec n'a pas le temps de te faire
descendre pour rentrer ça ça paraît
assez délicat donc là encore on a une
jauge à gauche mais en fait qui est une
fausseau je crois qui est c'est de la
jojette quoi
bah sinon si on t'a un peu sous pression
c'est un moyen d'égaliser plus ou moins
en force mais pas facile parce qu'en
plus il y a eu 4 c'est un coup
évidemment il pense depuis le début mais
depuis le début tu le rejettes à cause
de qui il prend des 5 et compagnie et là
qui prend des seins qui est toujours
pareil c'est juste que il se trouve que
tu retrouves le pion mais bon
c'est un peu évident de penser un coup
que ta banni jusqu'à là alors rien n'a
changé drastiquement dans la position
ouais enfin c'est oui
ordinateur sont rarement trouvables
parce que ça joue sur des détails des
petites nuances dans des variantes qui
marchent de justesse et maintenant il
reste plus que 3 minutes 10 Ania le
Sarine Fabien la pendule qui va
peut-être jouer dans cette partie
attention quand même parce que on va
être on va rentrer dans dans la zone de
danger dans la zone rouge dans la zone
gaffe et avec une position très
difficile à jouer côté blanc Niall
Sarine déjà en grand danger il a pris en
C4 il a joué qui avait lieu 6 et là
évidemment la jauge rentre dans le dans
le terrain du rester en 5 mais c'est
c'est pas loin de rentrer dans le 6
[Musique]
ça pourrait faire mal Fabien
attention 5 qui le sauve un petit peu
non
mais genre par là que tu vas pas
calculer plus loin que ça là tu as
l'impression avec les noirs de temps
sortir donc c'est peut-être ça qui va
permettre à anial d'empêcher cette ligne
même si scientifiquement parlant elle ne
marche pas Fabien
cliquement parlant elle marche
c'est peut-être un détail pour vous mais
ça fait une grande différence
alors comment Wesley va traiter ça sur
dessin que le cavalier pourrait jaillir
vers la case C5 Fabien
parce qu'en fait le juste pour finir la
variante donc c'était quoi c'était 5 tu
regardes ici 8 et 8 qui avait ça c'était
quoi en fait c'est genre
G4 ça devient imparable et 6 ou kg 6
c'est ça
mettons les couilles les dessins
mais oui
c'est ça
bon pas évident enfin je veux dire une
fois tu as le truc sous les yeux tu vois
bien dame G4
et C8 qui a valu F5 c'est jouer en fait
c'est trouver par Wesley assez
impressionnant sur cette séquence de
coupe à bien on va pas évident parce que
c'était dur
bah ouais ouais faut avoir qui est
français 5 c'est de l'eau quoi
bah c'est bien joué
c'est très très bien joué par par Wesley
peut-être un premier coup de griffe du
Chat celui-là il fait mal en plus contre
si tu perds la deuxième au noir tu vas
ouais bon tu te fais fermer et tu te
fais fermer ouais
très très très bien joué de la part de
Wesley so qui qui met à malin le joueur
indien d'entrée de jeu il coûte pas là
hop on avait dit que ce cette partie de
tableau basse a été quand même nettement
moins forte sembler tu es la première
partie le haut du tableau qui qui frappe
et qui fait très très mal
enfin faire attention
[Musique]
qui file après bon il a fait la même
chose hier et avant-hier par de la
première comme ça avec les Noirs après
il a su revenir donc on va on va suivre
mais dès la prochaine ça va être
important
ça va être crucial même
ce que la finale est en deux jours alors
oui la finale est aussi en deux jours là
faut qu'il ait le dame F3 encore
mais il va peut-être la voir
il y a peu de doutes incroyable on a
retrouvé cette vente c'est bien joué de
la part de Wesley complètement c'est
très bien joué c'est très bien trouvé
c'est très bien manipuler par par le
joueur américain
qui va pouvoir comme ça d'entrer de jeu
au fait on a pas eu le fameux
on n'a pas eu le fin mot Fabien de se B6
mais il montre qu'il est il est fort
quelque part qui lui a permis de faire
tourner le match au final
la balle est
déjà foutu ça et oui parce qu'il y a
l'idée de dame G4 qui est après c'était
trouvable il peut connaître un saut
c'est thème d'attaque parce qu'il y a
quand même beaucoup de pièces et c'est
pas des thèmes qu'on voit jamais c'est
ces attaques là donc c'est des choses
qui sont thématiques qui sont trouvables
mais trouver ça avec cinq minutes 50 sur
la pendule en une minute c'est c'est ou
une minute trente c'est quand même assez
assez impressionnant et là il y a le
tissu complètement il comprend même pas
ce qu'il lui arrive en fait le pauvre
dépassé par par la vitesse de Wesley
griffes affûté ma griffe activité totale
du chat enfin un chat ça allait très
très bon réflexes quand même et là ça y
est il commence à comprendre pourquoi il
est foutu il a mis du temps mais ça y
est on voit sur sur son visage qui
comprend le fond du problème
donc il échange d'un point de toute
façon ça change rien la tour est
peut-être mieux en un et on veut de
toute façon partir vers G4 ça a été
prémouvant plus hein Wesley mais là la
tête dans le seau les dames GK BIM ah
ouais c'est impressionnant Wesley de
gala ce soir dans sa tenue d'étoiles
alors là il va comment il va terminer
alors le coût de l'ordi assez magnifique
c'est tout aussi
trouvable
mais normalement qui va pas être joué
parce que il y a trop de gains
on va peut-être plutôt partir sur du H6
G6 qui est écran G6 puis on prend un G6
Fabien peut-être
qui semble être quand même plus plus
simple sans être forcément compliqué sur
H6 peut-être qu'il y aura G5 dans ces
cas-là
mais bon
cavalier F3 peut-être simplement suivi
d'un sacrifice en tout cas Wesley ou
peut-être même F4 Wesley qui réfléchit
ici j'ai envie de dire Fabien à bon
escient
c'est le moment de de faire un stop et
il le fait peut-être un coup comme
cavalier G6 aussi tu peux aussi aller
faire un tour en G6
parce que les Noirs ne veulent pas
prendre mais le problème c'est que bon
c'est un peu relou si tu me NAS
probablement qu'elle va aller H6 et sur
pion prend il y avait c'est la partie et
là ça va être tout reprendre
pour essayer de s'en sortir mais
m'attend m'attendais ou même que il
prend ça
à l'air ouais ouais on est plus content
cavalier est trop fort ici voici qui
prend là encore son temps il veut pas
laisser la moindre chance à anial mais
tu reprends le 7 fous prends le 7 la
jauge annonce mathensif
pour essayer d'embrouiller mais
ça s'appelle ça s'appelle en zéro Wesley
impressionnant Royal serein facile
ni elle Sarine qui n'a opposé quasiment
aucune résistance dans dans cette partie
on aurait cru Damien Benoît avec une
balle sur l'aile
non en fait je suis déjà parti à
l'intérieur regarde là c'est la ligne de
trousse frère
la France bon match bon match bon match
sur l'équipe de France qui j'ai pas
trouvé que c'était une grande France
mais ouais mais c'est les matchs qu'il
faut gagner
fabiennes shooter pas très bien ou c'est
un peu dur ou dans le combat tu étais
pas tu domines pas vraiment mais que
quand même tu réussis à les faire
tourner c'est les matchs importants les
équipes de l'hémisphère sud qui semble
un peu plus préparé là physiquement sur
sur ce début de tournée l'Argentine qui
allait gagner aujourd'hui Fabien en
Angleterre sur le score de 30 à 29
l'Afrique du Sud qui qui a failli aller
chercher une belle équipe d'Irlande à
l'extérieur alors que l'Irlande est
quand même numéro enfin France - Irlande
et Nouvelle-Zélande c'est numéro 1 2 3
mondial après décider de votre ordre les
néo-zélandais qui ont infligé un 55 à 23
au Pays de Galles
qui a quand même tué on sent que les
équipes de l'hémisphère sud là sont
vraiment très affûtés après le rugby
champion de chips et gagner un match
comme ça un peu au couteau mener de 4
points à 10 minutes de la fin c'est moi
je trouve que c'est plutôt de bonne
augure
ah non mais c'est bien de toute façon
enfin mais dans le contenu
un peu chiant quoi
ouais puis laisser qui nous mettent
aussi en début de match les Australiens
il est assez extraordinaire il faut dire
quand il court ouais
sur un ballon un peu au pied machin le
ballon à 4 mètres de leur ligne et puis
deux fois sur 90
en fait c'est jusqu'à un moment donné il
y a des cannes
et la deuxième partie est à 19h et oui
un deuxième partie à 19h donc une
demi-heure de jeu une demi-heure de
pause
halfenhower of play half hour of pose
c'est
pas pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
non mais la finale j'espère que tu as vu
la fin du du Djoko moi j'ai pas pu voir
les deux premiers
[Musique]
incroyable rune
vraiment il joue vraiment très très très
très bien
il se repose il regarde les ouvertures
lâche je sais pas entre ça la prochaine
c'est sûr qu'il regarde parce que ça
peut retomber sur la même chose mais ça
là je sais pas mais là ça fait ça peut
vraiment être une finale à sens unique
Fabien moi ou pas
en tout cas ça part pour
non mais le truc c'est que
il a gagné la première
Guiri c'est quand même moins fort que
Wesley il a perdu la deuxième tempo et
puis le jour 2 il a regagné la première
donc la 5e du match et il a perdu la 6e
bon
voilà
c'est quand même moins moins solide
ouais je sais pas enfin oui mais bon
des parcours similaires qu'on ne s'est
pas mené aussi donc chaque fois il est
revenu après évidemment normalement tu
es pas ravi de commencer derrière là
dans la partie il a pas existé une
énorme différence donc forcément au vu
de ça tu dis bon ben il va prendre cher
mais bon allez on va laisser le doute au
vu des autres matchs on verra bien mais
dès la prochaine c'est hyper important
évidemment c'est hyper la seconde ou
s'il
n'anecdotique avec les Blancs ça sent
pas bon si les mené deux points à la fin
de la journée c'est quoi c'est fini
déjà ça peut aller vite je suis en train
de regarder ce qu'ils font j'essaye de
savoir s'ils reprennent quand même pas
un petit peu avant parce que c'est
pourquoi faire
quand même la pause avant tout en fait
ils font pas des pauses à plein de gars
qui discutent en fait
enfin c'est pas plein de gars c'est sûr
les mêmes gars non ça y est c'est la
pause ou pas attends
il répète ce qu'on dit en fait
ils disent que ça rime recommence une
nouvelle fois un match en perdant mais
qui
rediscute de la partie encore une
quatrième je sais pas j'ai l'impression
qu'il débrief 50 fois la même partie en
fait
ça a été un problème pour Sarine avec
les Noirs mais bon ça enfin j'arrive un
monde pas la poudre quoi
la même ligne que que
il a pris un petit avantage et Machin
enfin en fait oui il répète tout ce
qu'on a dit pendant la partie
tu as raison ils savent pas quoi dire en
fait
non mais objectivement bah non mais bon
tu peux rien dire en fait si tu as
inventé
non mais c'est certain
en fait il y a juste rien à dire
malheureusement il n'y a pas grand chose
à dire ouais
mais à la fiche de ne pas super envie
quoi
et je regarde en fait
[Musique]
il a besoin de se chauffer pour les
matchs mais qu'après il joue beaucoup
mieux quoi
c'est dommage de pas penser à ses
cheveux avant le match en fait
c'est juste que bon ok il est plus
faible et que contre guérison c'est pas
trop enfin guéri par tout ça et c'est
viande c'est juste qu'il rate des
positions complètement gagnantes enfin
c'est pas qui se chauffe en fait
c'est beau qu'en fait il répète que je
conduis oui bon il a quand même bien
jouer avec les Blancs ça rien oui enfin
c'est ce qu'on dit enfin je vais jouer
en fait
j'espère qu'ils vont pas pause pour
faire ça c'est que j'espère que c'est
juste je sais pas bon et dépose prévu
parce que bon il est pose prévu
pour les discussions de sofa quoi ah
ouais non mais bon ok
[Musique]
on s'en fout en fait ça va si il y a 10
minutes de pause pour meubler mais en
fait ils vont tu peux pas meubler une
demi-heure avec ça c'est pas possible
mais en fait j'ai l'impression qu'ils
veulent copier d'autres jeux
mais
[Musique]
sauf que ça marche pas pour les échecs
en fait
parce qu'en fait tu vois sur League of
Legends immeuble un peu comme ça mais en
fait le truc c'est qu'il te montre des
ralentis d'actions qui sont passés et du
coup ils te font des palettes
ralenti tu peux pas parce qu'en fait il
y a rien à dire mais en fait dans dans
les autres jeux ils te demandent des
bras lentilles des actions mécaniques
des joueurs et Machin et t'as pas pu
tout voir pendant mais après tu as la
palette à Doudouce
ah ouais non maintenant ils mettent un
best of ben non
mais en fait
il te montre la caméra de s reine
[Musique]
Mo et je sais pas qui pendant
l'Armageddon d'hier et à zéro public
mais quand tu vois la finale de League
of Legends hier tu as des salles
remplies tu as 5000 personnes dedans les
gens ils gueulent enfin c'est sûr qu'il
y a des trucs à montrer en fait
c'est pas trois commentateurs qui se
battent en duo et qui regardent une
partie quoi
qui a été explique pourquoi l'Armageddon
est rapide là
il te dit qu'en fait ils ont trouvé que
c'était pas logique de faire un
Armageddon en blitz pour un tournoi
rapide et que c'était normal de le faire
en rapide du coup
ça va être bien on va faire des armées
mais c'est bizarre parce qu'en fait il
change des trucs qui sont bien aux
échecs genre en fait aux échecs les gens
ont toujours aimé les blitz de partage
ça a toujours été un truc que tout le
monde a kiffé enfin même je me rappelle
pendant ce n'est pas du tout pourquoi
faire des tirs au but alors que les mecs
ne courent plus
faisons trois heures de plus de match
c'est bizarre de changer les enfin
d'enlever les trucs que les gens aiment
dans les tournois
ouais c'est marrant
ah non mais si ils sont très contents il
y a un autre qui dit que c'est très très
bien il est très fan de cette arnaque et
non plutôt que de refaire un truc en
blitz quoi
les audiences incroyable pour
il y a beaucoup plus de monde là que
[Musique]
pour d'autres et notamment je pense que
quand on aura le speechester qui va
reprendre
on verra la différence
en fait
c'est intéressant
c'est très étonnant en fait passer
intéressant de regarder leur truc mais
c'est très étonnant
par curiosité
[Musique]
S
montre un endroit Toronto ils font des
tournois dans un dans un bar
à la pause tu pourras pas voir ça
[Musique]
je sais pas c'est très très étrange
inspire toi des meilleurs
très étrange en fait
il va le faire un truc qui ressemble un
peu entre la télé et twitch et
un truc un peu entre les deux en fait
[Musique]
vidéo bizarres de 30 secondes
mais oui en fait c'est plus en mode
émission là ce qu'ils font qui peut être
sympa pour un talk show genre après les
candidats au quoi mais au milieu d'une
compétition c'est très bizarre en fait
je sais pas c'est un truc après
après ouais mais normalement le but du
condition c'est que ça joue c'est pas
qu'il y a des pauses en permanence
je pense qu'ils ont mal calibrer le
les tailles des pauses en fait
intuitivement tu te dis on joue 20
minutes on fait 50 minutes de pause ça
semble bien sur le principe bon pratique
un peu moins c'est dommage on pouvait
pas prévoir avant c'était trop dur
[Musique]
ouais non ça se voit qu'ils ont juste
mal calibré
c'est assez étonnant ils ont dû vouloir
faire un truc lisible en disant on joue
une fois toutes les heures
et au moins on
[Musique]
peut-être que la cadence est trop rapide
en fait bah ouais en fait c'est
peut-être la cadence qui va pas elles
sont partis principes de jouer une fois
toutes les heures ils ont voulu mettre
un truc pour être bien sûr de jamais
déborder
mais au final tu peux enfin tu peux pas
en fait
dû faire 20 plus de
[Musique]
après ils auraient pu faire 10 + 2 et
faire deux parties en fait blanc noir à
l'enchaîner et puis faire une pause
après
c'est étonnant
on fait une petite pause on revient à 55
[Musique]
on a été pris de cours heureusement
qu'on n'est pas parti ils ont décidé de
raccourcir la pose en fait de ne pas
suivre l'horreur de ne pas suivre
l'horaire alors attends donc du coup ben
complètement pris de cours une nouvelle
fois
mais bon pas facile parce que
les horaires sont enfin ouais ils sont
jamais suivi quoi non
[Musique]
après tant mieux c'est plutôt bien ah
bah là on gagne on gagne 7 minutes là on
est très heureux
mais je comprends après ça reprend plus
à 53 de manière un peu arbitraire mais
bon enfin c'est tant mieux on va pas
s'en plaindre parce que c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle
ça permet de mettre un peu de rythme
dans cette finale tout à fait c'est
peut-être 20 minutes de pause du coup
peut-être qu'ils sont rendus compte
qu'il risquaient de se prendre aussi des
nuls en trois minutes avec les Blancs
et donc ça pourrait ça pourrait rendre
les choses compliquées
en tout cas parlons peu parlons bien
petite catalane pour
pour NiAl alors attends le bon sens et
ben voilà on est on a tout comme il faut
ouais bon
ouais c'est une variante un peu solide
des Noirs c'est symétrique souvent les
blancs prennent en C5 je crois que tu
peux peut-être le donner lui aussi
le D4 bon bah ce qu'il a fait
c'est un peu le même esprit que la
partie d'avant dans le sens où c'est un
peu chiant à jouer pour les Noirs mais
ça doit aller quoi
ouais c'est un peu relou quand même
pas beaucoup mais
tu préfères quand même avoir les blancs
un peu chiant
c'est beau quand on négocie quoi
non non mais ça peut ça peut je sais pas
en fait j'imagine que il connaît bien
quoi en fait donc ça dépend à quel point
tu connais jusqu'où
j'espère qu'il connaît encore pour lui
bah pourquoi c'est chiant simplement on
a deux pions sans trop contre un on a le
fougé deux qui tape on peut avoir des 4
fois F4 pour C1 en fait on a un peu de
vent je sais pas ça se voit c'est visuel
voilà que les Noirs ils ont du mal à
sortir le fou c'est vite déjà
voilà bon après
oui comme je te dis ça dépend peut-être
tu peux sécher le truc t'activer
bon bah déjà ce qui est clair c'est que
tu vas pas tout le reste qui est à 57
ans quoi donc
tu vas leur dire
ça marche ou pas mais il a joué 7 mais
peut-être juste il connaît en fait
ah mais si c'est théorique entre
guillemets qui connaît tu peux égaliser
en force juste parce que tu sais bah
c'est oui
et peut-être que tu as toujours su
d'ailleurs
compliqué ouais
en tout cas jolie fini dans la première
partie ah ouais
ça fait un peu
les combos final dans les Tekken ou les
trucs comme ça quoi
là j'ai l'impression qu'il se fait
sécher NiAl c'est pas comme contre rien
[Musique]
ou non bien loin de là non pas du tout
qui arrive pas à progresser à passer un
palier là il bloque depuis deux ans
peut-être il bloque sur un palier mais
bonjour Après mais oui c'est pas top top
top c'est un excellent joueur attention
mais on parle pour top monde
il faut toujours remettre dans le
contexte de la question il est nettement
plus fort que nous hein ça arrive mais
disons par rapport à des joueurs du Top
20 mondial il est très faible il arrive
pas faire le petit jump là qui lui
permettrait de monter mais après c'est
un déclic oui ça peut venir peut-être
plus tard il est encore jeune après
puis si bouge pas de là ça restera un
bon joueur mais qui oui voilà pourra pas
jouer pour prétendre à la couronne
mondiale quoi
ni même pour une car il faut candidat
actuellement
non après bon avec un petit coup de
chance on sait jamais ouais mais il est
quand même plutôt le niveau en dessous
oui oui non mais en dessous complètement
mais quand on a vu qu'Alex & Co c'était
qualifié tu vois je trouve pas beaucoup
moins fort qu'avec cinq quoi par exemple
non mais il est un peu de ce niveau là
quoi mais tu faisais mais bon après Alex
and Co oui bon il a fait les candidats
mais il a fait dernière enfin il a pas
eu de miracle
en fait nous ce qui est marrant c'est
pragada et ça arrive on y a jamais trop
cru
non mais réellement
oui il pouvait le devenir top enfin ils
peuvent encore devenir top mondial mais
genre par là qu'on les ai jamais
rien d'époustouflant complètement tu
sais qui peuvent mais tu sais qui
peuvent pas aussi enfin
ils peuvent s'arrêter ils peuvent
s'arrêter
plus sérieux
après attention quand même là on est
dans une période un peu particulière ce
que tu vois tu m'aurais demandé il y a
trois mois ni man ça avait l'air d'être
assez probable aussi
j'ai jamais trop compris ce qu'il
faisait quoi
[Musique]
quand un concert à parler de lui sur sur
twitch
moi non plus mais bon
il faut
on peut plus rien savoir en fait
maintenant
donc c'est une période un petit peu
complexe donc c'est très difficile de
s'exprimer sur sur les jeunes joueurs
parce que il y a
il y a des interactions sur leur
progression sur comment ils ont
progressé sur
enfin voilà c'est difficile maintenant
de savoir
mais bon a priori donc
chez les jeunes ouais donc les Indiens
les deux meilleurs du moment c'est
Google c'est organisé après on va voir
ce qu'ils vont donner mais c'est les
deux qui ont passé les 2007 donc à voir
on le verra en speechasse notamment
il semble pouvoir y arriver mais après
voilà il y a on verra mais de toute
façon on a toujours eu plus ou moins le
truc avec les jeunes à dire bah que la
vie il peut se passer des trucs tu peux
avoir
tu arrêtes de progresser ou tu as
d'autres son intérêt ou se passe bon peu
importe donc on sait pas après c'est
genre qui peuvent ça arrive déjà à la
que 18 ans là ça va en fait il va il va
encore progresser on sera un joueur qui
passera les 2007 dans sa vie a priori
après jusqu'où tu vois ça peut être un
joueur sera de 1720 par là une sorte
d'Harry Krishna c'est une belle carrière
c'est déjà oui on aimerait bien avoir la
même c'est très clairement mais tu sais
pas
visite aussi qu'il y a une belle
carrière
qui bouge pas trop c'est ça 2720 30 10
ça dépend mais du rabattre bon joueur
solide il peut pas être n'importe qui
peut même pas de 45 sur une partie il
est là
d'ailleurs il y a pas si longtemps dans
une partie importante en Coupe d'Europe
donc c'est des joueurs qui peuvent qui
peuvent qui peuvent battre des tops
mondiaux qui peuvent mettre en danger
n'importe qui mais qui réussissent pas à
faire ce petit jump quoi
mais après du coup les Indiens ils sont
très nombreux ça va devenir probablement
la nation numéro aux échecs
parce que tu vois même des joueurs qui
sont pas mauvais genre adyban je sais
même pas s'il est encore dans le top 10
des années quoi
ah il est pas mauvais hein celui qu'on
appelle the beast ouais la bête la bête
qu'un joueur qui facilite
exactement
[Musique]
2630 tout ça ils existent plus trois
qui est un peu plus de mon âge mais qui
comment il s'appelle
[Musique]
très bon aussi
j'ai déjà perdu donc qui a ton âge
ouais par là un peu plus jeune
mais tant mais il est 26 et quelques
[Musique]
je veux connaître très bien non non
je vais voir dans ma liste de parties
perso comme ça et pendant qu'on discute
des échecs indiens pendant les signes je
crois que c'est juste mieux là ça il
peut quasiment clôture ado le macho
ça serait pas trop mal enfin bravo lui
allez Wesley allez le chat les griffes
sont sortis
et pareil en fait tu vois ils ont
[Musique]
tous ces gamins en fait ils sont
tellement nombreux en un maintenant
qu'on y pense même plus à
rien
mais clairement il a été champion du
monde junior je crois
upta peut-être
sympa tout ça je veux deux fois plus je
parle deux fois
et il joue bien enfin il fait des Open
bon alors bien sûr il y a un style de
jeu des fois un peu tout moche ou quoi
mais il est non c'est fermé mais c'est
vrai qu'ils ont une tendance comme ça à
bloquer quoi mais après beaucoup de
joueurs bloquent aussi en tellement dur
de rentrer dans le dans le top top nous
on est quand même gâté en France avec
deux joueurs au top niveau
bah qui a quand même trois même ouais
non mais on a trois joueurs dans le 4
joueurs dans le top 100
actuellement c'est bien on est quand
même j'imagine ils sont plus
ouais mais je préfère notre situation
alors parce que nous on en a un qui peut
devenir champion du monde pour le moment
et eux non
mais genre si tu compares
beaucoup plus ancienne que la France
enfin en tout cas nous un joueur qui
peut être champion du monde pendant 10
ans si concrètise bon eux peut-être
aussi mais peut-être pas peut-être pas
on verra mais nous oui non
un jour plus fort que toi on a un
meilleur pays que toi on est plus fort
des cinq
ouais bon bah oui les noirs sont mieux
enfin je veux dire mais
[Musique]
en fait le problème dans ces structures
tiens juste pour en revenir là c'est que
certes les blancs montage au centre mais
non bah c'est éloigner à terme dans
toutes les finales c'est pas trop mal ce
[ __ ] ils ont de la colonne aussi
oui et donc tu peux pas faire tourner un
Tapion à deux prix toujours ado il y
aura peut-être des fois 4 qui ont été
arrivé dessus dès qu'il a essayé d'eux
des machins donc en fait c'était bien
agencé les pièces ils connaissait en
fait je pense mais c'est ça le problème
en fait comme je te dis ça c'est une
position je sais pas c'est vrai que
visuellement ça a l'air cool plutôt cool
pour les blancs mais en fait ça va point
final en fait tu sacrifies B7 tu
t'actives enfin d'ailleurs il a même pas
pris mais peut-être il fallait prendre
en fait quand même oui c'est normal tu
es pas moins bien que les Blancs tu te
fais sécher c'est tout là tu peux être
pire que ça qui en fait tu peux être
essoré
était déjà mené à zéro exactement donc
double essorage tu peux ne pas être bien
et ne pas taper par rame
exactement
c'est compliqué là pour pour ni à la
marche et peut-être trop haute c'est
vrai tu imagines n'a qu'à c'est pour ça
aussi qu'il était aussi dégoûté hier on
en parlait mais parce que tu sais que si
tu vas Wesley pour NACA je pense que
c'est vraiment freewin Sarine c'est
juste le style en plus qui lui
correspond c'est pour tu te nourris là
qui te tombent dessus tu les regardes
tomber quoi c'est l'hélicoptère monnaie
qui vont tu peux faire un peu le malin
tac tac tac machin faire tes petites
danses bouffer ta salade faire là c'est
tout ce dont tu rêves en fait pour Naka
[Musique]
pas vraiment de belle casse tu reviens
tu vas te prendre foi à 3 et si tu fais
F3 tu es dégoûté quoi enfin tu as pas
fait la Catalane pour mettre un pion F3
mais bon si tu as pas le choix tu as pas
le choix
ah ça y est ça commence à pleurifier
côté Wesley mais bon la position est
tellement belle surtout pour le coup
faut que c'est un énorme classique dans
plein de trucs ghetto quoi tu es content
d'aller perdre ton temps pour pour
juste pas mauvais tu bloques le pion tu
replaces le fou peut-être tu joues un
petit tour vite enfin ça va très bien
mais je l'aimais bien
il n'y a pas pu bétonner que so on dit
ouais c'est pour ça qu'on disait si
réussi à gagner avec les noirs qui te
met de zéro bon
il arrive ses écouteurs attention triche
il remet ses écouteurs interdits
éliminatoire disqualification
oh bah non mais ça c'est pas autorisé à
mon avis par le règlement il a peut-être
entendu ce que disait
Reichs attention au cas où oui
moi j'ai changé de coach là
8 semble logique à triche caractérisée
quand même là Fabien
il a arrêté d'écouter de la musique donc
forcément
triche caractérisée
le fou ici donc ouais il s'est pas
bloqué dans le pion dessin qui se remet
de l'autre côté
il colle le matin un peu pas de Tours 2
pas de Tours
tout à l'heure vraiment étonnant qu'il
est pas joué mais bon c'est c'est du
Wesley c'est pas les coûts les plus
agressifs mais c'est diablement efficace
on l'a vu hier son point fort à Wesley
quand il a défendu cette position que
très peu auraient pu défendre Fabien
bah ouais parce qu'il y avait des
fourchettes il faut être pleuvoir de
partout il y avait trois pièces sur le
roi et il est resté stoïque
il est vraiment il est vraiment fort il
est pétri talent ce joueur et c'est
peut-être ça il pêche simplement un
petit peu mentalement
problème qu'il aura jamais réussi à
régler au cours de sa carrière et qu'il
a peut-être empêché de voir plus haut
en tout cas
il fait des bons résultats et puis il
repêche plus tard
ça revient là pendant quelques mois et
puis il arrive tout ça il arrive tout
simplement pas pareil tu vois là il mène
un zéro et tout de suite tout de suite
tout de suite les coûts les plus plâtres
il arrive vraiment pas à
se motiver par motiver c'est pas le
terme mais à faire abstraction un peu
du côté
de la tension et de l'enjeu surtout au
contraire il pourrait de par cette
première victoire se tranquilliser se
relâcher un peu tranquille
il mène au score il peut il peut être
serein mais mais non il continue quand
même à vouloir fermer à tout prix
on va avoir en tout cas peut-être
qu'après fou des trois il va
ouvrir ça va quand même pas trop mal
pour lui la position c'est pas le
problème mais c'est dur maintenant de
voir un plan pour
être les blancs enfin peut-être un peu
mieux mais tu fais quoi en fait enfin
peut-être que là il veut juste rien
faire h68
je passe mon tour vas-y joue quoi
difficile
fougère maintenant un petit peu à
contretemps mais c'était peut-être
toujours le bon coup quoi qu'il en soit
en tout cas c'était payant cette
stratégie hier pour West puisqu'il Caro
a fini par perdre un peu tout seul il a
perdu un peu le fil et c'est vrai qu'il
est très déstabilisant à ne jamais
attaquer et tout d'un coup il se met un
contre un peu sorti de nulle part
après pourquoi pas il veut peut-être
devenir un F3 il a traqué par par
derrière le pion des cinq et par la même
occasion enfermé un peu ce roi sur sur
cette première rangée il pourrait faire
d'une pierre deux coups ici Wesley
un petit peu moins bien autant dans
cette partie 5 minutes 12 contre 8
minutes mais la position se joue assez
simplement côté noir
demande si ce serait une sorte de Neo
petroscien si on veut pourquoi pas on
peut faire un peu le parallèle c'est
vrai que c'est un peu le même style
il y a des similitudes mais il y a aussi
Sarine qui propose à accepter
automatiquement par Wesley
ça ne m'intéresse pas voilà
bon un peu dommage peut-être s'il y a
une passe match
il est plutôt mieux mais bon rien n'est
fait en tout cas pour l'instant belle
gestion du match il a toujours pas été
mis en difficulté mais un an et demi à
0,5 et il aura les blancs la prochaine
et peut-être tu pourras mettre la
pression en tout cas Sarine
contrairement à ces matchs congrès n'est
pas arrivé à réagir dans la foulée de sa
défaite même il était passé proche de la
correctionnel donc début de match
maîtrisé pour son en tout cas maîtriser
et du coup je vais essayer d'aller
comprendre un quel est le
timing prévu maintenant par par la
compétition parce que si on se fait une
pause direct maintenant et on se dit
dans 20 minutes on pense peut-être la
prochaine à 32 puis bon au pire on me
blublera en attendant quoi
on peut dire 30 au moins un peu de
risques
sur le live américain quand même le
téléphone avec moi voilà c'est ça et si
jamais je vois le live américain qui
reprend parce que j'ai compris
maintenant alors leur méta je te le dis
vas-y à tout de suite allez ça marche
[Musique]
et on est de retour les amis pour pour
la troisième partie donc ouais c'est des
pauses de 20 minutes apparemment c'est
en fait c'est maximum ça peut pas
dépasser et j'ai un peu regardé le cas
de chess comme moi en fait il y a des
blagues il y a des machins bon
en fait ils filent des blagues en avance
ils font des petits sketchs quoi
je sais pas si tu connais Maxime Biaggi
Maxime
là c'est des
donc c'est très malaisant enfin ouais
c'est de l'humour malaisant mais qui est
drôle parce qu'il est malaisant quoi il
est fait exprès mais c'est que Dany qui
se retrouve dans des situations
malaisante quoi
mais bon c'est un peu toujours les mêmes
blagues quand même c'est très épais
c'est très redondant et répétitif
drôle de par la gênance en fait
c'est très malaise TV mais c'est une
forme d'humour en fait de faire ça après
on aime ou on n'aime pas ça c'est une
autre question mais c'est une
forme d'humour on peut pas le nier
non on va on va attendre là ça devrait
bien te reprendre je pense à 33
en fait c'est magnifique ce que je pense
que ça je vais pouvoir voir Toulon
Montpellier ce soir bah peut-être ce
serait ça serait très beau
bon j'ai rien prévu de voir ce soir mais
bon
si ça peut ne pas finir à 23h pour voir
ça c'est pas mal non mais là c'est sûr
ça peut plus finir à 23h en fait deux
parties et je pense maximum ça termine à
20h30 à 21h
mais ça peut terminer à 20h20 20h30
parce que
il est tellement fou
en fait ils ont proposé nul ça a été
accepté
j'ai l'impression qu'ils allongent un
peu la pause quand même
il doit être un peu pris de court
par la vitesse de jeu
[Musique]
c'est vrai que ça clique très vite
ma deuxième partie tu pouvais quand même
pas faire plus court quoi 10 minutes
c'est peu
non
15 minutes déjà ça va aller
métier
peut juste prendre nu l'instant non
en fait oui il a pas de raison de faire
le con avec les Noirs faut qu'il fasse
nul s'il peut faire nul avec les plantes
tu veux dire là il a les blancs
il se jette sur une île dès maintenant
il est déjà en gestion où il essaye
quand même un peu de jouer non mais je
pense qu'il va jouer vite fait et mais
bon tu vois la partie d'avance ça me
donne pas l'impression qu'il a envie de
spécialiser ben marquer un autre point
tant qu'il fera nul je serai heureux je
pense parce qu'il y a pas de raison
qu'il est plus dans cette partie que ce
qu'il avait la partie d'avant
tout à fait d'accord avec toi
je suis 200% d'accord avec toi Fabien
c'est pour ça que je demande est-ce que
il va même pas juste
aller chercher la petite draw quoi
on va voir en tout cas peut-être une
nulle en moins de 2 minutes peut-être ça
va jouer
moi je suis conseillerais quand même de
jouer un peu un point c'est pas assez en
fait non
tu peux pas gaspiller tes blancs pour
rien comme ça
surtout que si tu en gagnes une deuxième
avec les Blancs tu ouais
par contre Simonet 2 0 là tu peux faire
déjà bah oui
bon ils nous ont eu c'était
ça va jouer je pense
je pense que ça va partir là ils
attendent le feu vert mais c'est sûr que
ça appartient
c'est un peu particulier c'est nul par
accord bon c'est quand même les règles
du jeu
non mais après c'est vrai que on
pourrait dégager ça
après tu peux l'enlever si tu veux
l'enlever mais je en soit ça fait partie
des règles
ça me choque pas personnellement des
nulle rapide non encore moins en match
parce qu'à la fin il y a un vainqueur et
un éliminé donc une stratégie de match
on va dire
faut prendre le match dans sa globalité
en fait c'est pas une partie prise comme
ça c'est séparément c'est un match de 8
parties et voilà alors c'est parti alors
ça y joue des modernes quoi donc il veut
essayer de compliquer un peu le jeu donc
avoir comment Wesley va traiter ça ce
qui fait C4 pour aller plus dans du D4
et ce qui fait qu'il s'est trois normal
et ce qui fait des ventes solides à base
de Keye F3 C3 et compagnie voilà c'est
les trois choix on va dire
[Musique]
H4 en général c'est c'est recommandé tu
pousses un pot tout simplement
bien sûr qui est extra c'est un coup H3
conservateurs
mais ça pourrait devenir un jour mais
c'est un peu l'idée d'avoir de maintenir
ce qui est danger de l'entendre H4 H6
pas mal il veut pas faire H5 avec les
noirs pour ne pas donner la cage G5 là
tu peux faire H5 et de gagner la H5 G5
F4 là le truc tu fais pour ouvrir le jeu
tout à fait c'est assez logique si tu
peux aussi
avoir fait un grand rock et retarder
pour après mais H5 G5 F4
priori c'est pas mauvais choix
on va voir ce qui décide il connaît de
toute façon encore là aussi
la position c'est sûr oui oui
on va avoir un ski décide de faire
il a tout un tas de choix dans sa manche
et il hésite il peut proposer nul
ce qui serait beau
mais bon il peut quasi tu es le match
oui
et au pire il perd et il lui arrive rien
de grave quoi et
c'est vrai que tu as une tranquillité
quand tu prends le lead comme ça très
tôt
tranquillité d'esprit il joue avec F3
donc il joue encore un système différent
mais il a l'Espace il a tout pour lui à
Wesley
ouais bon après il veut pas jouer pour
jouer 4g5 et 5 à ce moment-là et avoir
F4 F5 et partir comme ça quoi et ça
enfermé ici un cheval et qui avait H3
aussi c'est sûrement un coup pour les
blancs
on va voir quelle mise en place il
décide en tout cas il prend son temps ça
ride lui qui clique peut-être un peu
trop vite d'ailleurs
attention de pas à se mettre trop en
danger
bah écoute tu fais des coups normaux
après c'est vrai que les ordres de coupe
en or sont possibles mais il a censé top
il y a des élections H4 il aurait H6
c'est pas H5 donc là pour faire ses 5
ans
un peu
ouais bon
position à jamais facile à jouer pour
pour les noirs et pour les blancs il y a
pas de
percer 5
avec les Blancs tu as une décision
est-ce que je prends ces cinq ou pas si
tu prends pas il va continuer de temps
dessus si tu prends en général il prend
du cavalier et dans une structure
tissilienne dragon en fait
il va faire c'est ça hein
parce que tout le fouger 7 ça te fera
rien bon tu fermes le foot et en fait
c'est pas lui le danger
donc soit tu prends soit t'attendre te
faire prendre mais bon souvent tu le
prends parce que les normes vont
peut-être pas prendre et donc voilà
comme je te dis ta structure du dragon
et c'est une gueule de sicilienne tout
d'un coup
oui sur internet mais tu as le cavalier
8 enfin qu'il y a pas de mal à sortir
mais une fois que tu as fait cavalier F6
tu as pas petit rock non
et puis KFC c'est peut-être 5 qui est
désagréablement
là ici oui
pour faire cavalier F6 slash sur
rediriger
donc deux idées
[Musique]
je trouve que c'est jamais évident à
jouer avec les Blancs ces trucs là non
non c'est danger
pour tout le monde je veux dire mais les
Noirs c'est pas rien quoi
pas mal
tu as des plans quoi et des 5 donc qui
interdit pas complètement mais sur
cavalier 5 il veut peut-être se diriger
vers B6
plus ou moins normal bon sachant que les
Noirs ils peuvent aussi faire H5 ils ont
fait H6 au début et puis ils disent oui
bon j'ai envie de faire H5 comme ça je
perroquet
c'est pas c'est pas interdit quoi voilà
ouais
mais je pense que c'est le truc le plus
pleutre de la position non
mais c'est peut-être même pas mauvais
tu as d'autres choix mais tu peux faire
tu peux même faire foudre direct
peut-être tu peux aussi ramener le
cavalier en soutien de l'autre
tu peux faire plusieurs choses
c'est annoncé
ouais
là tu peux pas faire plus pleutre et là
du coup cavaler ces trois si on prend du
cavalier c'est qu'il est trois et
cavalid et cette fout des quatre à ce
moment-là
on peut pas jouer plus peu de que ça
femme
mais c'est peut-être pas mal pour les
blancs c'est peut-être bien joué il
garde le contrôle il laisse pas
attaqué facilement si tu as pas de casse
pas la Casa 5 tu as pas la caisse tu
peux pas faire des 4
tu es loin de faire qui est C4 donc
il rencontre l'eau est là il te met une
barricade en face commence par H5 mais
ça c'est c'est pas plus
mais je veux dire par là c'est ça garde
tous les mêmes plans dans la position
mais sur quel point H5 il veut quoi il
veut g46 pour bien échanger tout
je sais pas
moi je serais pas trop inquiet noir
[Musique]
H6 j'en ai rien à [ __ ] enfin tu me
fais de la chute
qui est ces trois MC5 ou C3
contrôler un peu ce cinquième rangée je
suis 3D 7 bon il faut acheter
[Musique]
OK
en tout cas il a 5 il a pris il faut
enfin de toute façon
après bon justement
tu peux aussi laisser les Noirs un peu
dans l'incertitude avec le recentre mais
là c'est pas c'est pas le but genre ça
pas trop de qui parce que si tu bouges
le cavalier parce que tu as envie de
faire le cahier pourra rebondir en G3 et
tu as pas forcément envie tu devras
repaire d'un train avec la tour ça
laissera le temps de H5 alors que G4
enfin en fait si tu avais un coup utile
genre fou des trois ouais
tu le ferais mais là tu as toutes tes
pièces enfin c'est ton cavalier qui doit
bouger
donc tu peux pas
donc G4 cavalier F6 vous prend H6 cet
échange tout et
tu te rapproches rapidement alors
attends est-ce que tu peux faire G4 kf6
vous prend un H6 cavalier G8
j'ai 5 cavaliers
6 et alors là c'est double tranchant
double tranchant
tu as peut-être des percées centrales un
moment un dessin qui pourra partir tu
vois ça fait plaisir de le faire
ah mais non mais alors on dit n'importe
quoi en fait il a pas joué ça du tout
Wesley
sacrifie la cale et il vient faire
cavalier 3 oui bon là il va falloir
quand même se calmer Wesley c'est trop
c'est beaucoup trop ce qu'il fait
ah mais en fait c'est pas du tout plein
non c'est pas l'autre
c'est pour ça qu'il est dur à jouer
Wesley
tout d'un coup je veux dire par là que
ça il est tellement pas imprévisible
c'est un peu comme ça qui a fait tourner
le match run tout à l'heure d'ailleurs
bon je sais que tu l'as pas vu mais
d'après ce que j'ai écouté ou quoi il
disait que dans le deuxième set il est
un peu changé un petit grain de folie
des petits coups un peu inattendus de
temps en temps et il t'a déréglé un peu
de Djoko comme ça en étant un peu fou
fou et Wesley il a enfin des fois c'est
ça c'est fait il joue 9 fois sur 10
l'autre et tout d'un coup tu sais pas
pourquoi il
t'envoie une dinguerie quoi
[Musique]
du calcul en fait ça devient une
position irrationnelle là il y a plus
rien à dire stratégiquement en fait
c'est qualité de plus mais tout est
bizarre parce que
tu as des trucs qui avance ok mais il
part sur le tour du fois je suis
[Musique]
pourquoi il a fait ça ouais c'est
bizarre quand même
qui pouvait faire un tranquille qui a
essayé 3 se faire sa petite nulle bah
c'est bizarre ça colle pas la stratégie
de match parce qu'en fait la partie
d'avant bah il est vraiment mieux pour
le gain on pressant tranquille sans
risque là c'est à risque enfin je te dis
pas que c'est majeur en fait
concrètement c'est pas forcément c'est
peut-être bon c'est peut-être mauvais on
n'en sait rien mais oui mais
il peut perdre
ça colle pas avec avec la stratégie de
match
mais bon après si c'était des machines
au cœur froid
ça se saurait
bon après c'est vrai que j'ai pas trop
de plans c'est un peu relou
mais bon
je sais pas trop comment agencer
exactement les pièces il va quand même
avoir un pion pour la cale oui
c'est pas rien
c'est-à-dire si tu prends un deuxième
pion était déjà devant le matériellement
avec les Blancs
après tu as pas de raison dans prendre
un deuxième enfin
actuellement
mais bon
truc c'est que ça joue beaucoup plus
facilement avec les Blancs c'est vrai
que je cherche aussi une tarif pas à
taper en fait non
peut-être tourner de dessin
autre plan c'est fou ces 6 tours B8 dame
B7 B4 enfin faut se déplacer pour aller
faire une perception en tout cas parce
que la tour G8 bon bah elle est là mais
[Musique]
faudrait pouvoir transférer ce tour
sinon via je sais pas où il y a G5 la G6
est tourné mais bon je vais remettre en
place tu vois là la jauge s'excite un
petit peu à cause de D5
ou tu as envie de faire enfin préparer
alors lui il le fait direct le champion
il va tourner 8 et c'est pas invisible
je veux dire ouais après des cinq pions
prend tour des 8 j'ai peut-être fou F4
quand même
et je vais te faire des si c'est
enfin je comprends que ça va être bon
en fait j'imagine
probablement
mais oui non mais bon tu peux ne pas
avoir envie de faire des cinq avec les
noirs et mais tu prépares
mettez 5 c'est fort en fait ouais
attendez
ça il est complètement pourri dans ce
structure il tape dans rien des cinq
d'un coup tu tapes F3 tu te remets vers
le centre tu regardes un roi c'est
logique en fait et de deux tu as une
qualité de plus donc tous des colonnes
une fois que le pion en D est passé tu
as ta torche G6 tour je sais pas où D6
par là-bas quoi quelque part donc
c'est un coup c'est noir ici à le faire
qui leur améliore leur position en tout
cas on va voir s'il y arrive bah c'est
tout
l'enjeu on va dire
complexe en position est-ce que les
blancs peuvent réussir à faire jouer ce
fou je pense qu'il a c'est trop long
parce que si tu réussis à le téléporter
en a deux tu serais beau
tu serais magnifique
ouais dorello qui propose un F2 pourquoi
pas c'est vrai que tu m'as saoulé ici
après ça va être pas très facilement par
tour des 7
mais bon soit peut-être d'un F2 pour les
peut-être vers H4 je ne sais quoi
pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas et peut-être qu'il y a les
F4 aussi qui empêche des cinq
on peut aussi aller le fond le pion et
laisser faire descendre
un peu en fait
trop bien
mais je préfère les Noirs c'est très
bizarre ce qu'a fait Wesley
[Musique]
qui existe tu danses de pions d'affilée
dans la tronche quoi
un peu irrationnel avec ce sacrifice de
qualité
mais ça fait aussi
un peu à la main c'est vrai c'est genre
thématique quoi
c'est pas ordinateur du tout
c'est hyper thématique alors après
peut-être qu'il veut 5 fou F2 D5 il y a
peut-être une dame qui arrivent qui va
vers H7 enfin non mais faut regarder
donc tu sais que ça marche mais je peux
comprendre là E5 fois F2 D5 damage 6
puis on prend le 4 tout 1
si on prend F3 dans H7 tu vois je sais
pas enfin c'est ou cavalier FC chaque
fou prendre à me prendre à ça en l'air
mais tu auras sûrement E4
quand même après
mais ça doit pas aller pour pour les
blancs il y a trop de pions
[Musique]
il y a aussi E5 fois F2 D5 fois 4
intermédiaire
mais là dessus tu as peut-être tourner 6
et cavaliers G3 pour essayer de profiter
du clouage pour faire kf5
en vrai son jauge c'est hyper compliqué
il va le faire
tu n'as pas méga envie quoi
ici tu vas te le prendre
E5 D5 évidemment tu fais E5 juste pour
rien faire tu peux pas non c'est le 5D 5
évidemment c'est un enchaînement c'est
un combo mais pour moi ça me coûte plus
intuitif en fait c'est ça le truc
mais parfois le calcul te fait refuser
des coups pareils
en tout cas il calcule il a gardé son
temps à bon escient il réfléchit au bon
moment
mais Wesley qui joue un peu à l'envers
cette partie
domine le match il fait une île sans
trop jouer la partie d'avant il a
peut-être eu un renne chambulant qui lui
a dit il faut quand même jouer un petit
peu plus frérot
ma stratégie étonnante
je
ne viens pas
après tu vas perdre rachis c'est quand
la dame vient tu auras encore F7 sous
pression il a fait 5
je pense que Sarine va la gagner
celle-là
oui mais en fait
bon choix d'ouvertures quelque part mais
sauf
et tout seul ce qu'il faut pas faire
quoi c'est à dire que il pouvait juste
maîtriser et là il rentre dans des
complications quand il était moins bien
autant et pour un truc super pas clair
c'est pas ou tu es mieux tu vois je
préfère le H5 F4 au début par exemple ah
bah c'est un F4 au début c'était cool
sûrement voilà là en fait tu fais un
truc super pas clair et je sais pas
le truc logique bah après on va voir si
si Wesley avait une idée cette fois H4
c'est dommage 7 ou quoi
[Musique]
mais bon tu t'auras tu seras sur une
case quand tu seras en dessin
façon il faut partir là-dedans côté
Wesley
ça sent l'égalisation
mais il a joué un peu contre le sens du
jeu
Wesley il est puni pas double contre
sens du match quand tu mènes et aussi du
jeu profil des joueurs et oui aussi tu
rentres dans le territoire où tu peux te
faire avoir par Sarine alors tu dominait
tranquillement en position calme la
partie 1 et 2 donc continue enfin tu as
trouvé un débat ou tu domines donc quand
tu le débat surtout quand tu t'appelles
sceau
si tu es en domination tu es quand même
très bien quoi
tu sors de ton pain quotidien quoi
tu t'appelles soit tu domines tu es le
roi du monde
mais peut-être sodominer trop facilement
et ça lui plaisait pas
préfère les matchs un peu plus serrés
peut-être Fabien
comme contre n'a qu'à en quelque sorte
je pensais tourner ici
[Musique]
en plus quand tu prends le 4 même si tu
te fais reprendre un jour il y aura G4
en l'air non mais c'est terrible
c'est une non partie quelque part
mais un peu
les noirs doivent rester vigilant c'est
vrai que tu as le droit a pris un peu
entre les quatre vents et qu'il faut H4
la colonne des têtes ouvertes c'est pas
terminé mais
bon je serais confiant avec les normes
parce qu'il y a rien qui marche pour
l'instant tu as l'avantage matériel
c'est en train d'ouvrir la position pour
tatouer tes tours d'ailleurs et puis ça
va permettre d'échanger des pièces donc
de repousser l'attaque blanche et voilà
peut-être quasi mieux prendre avec les
blancs en dessin en fait pas laisser
prendre et se laisser complètement
détruire la structure et c'est de garder
deux pions en vie là qui bloque un peu
la tour
mais bon on va sûrement tout reprendre
prise D1 et essayer de défendre ça
reste pas sympa
partie étrange
puis gros cette enfin tu vois bon ça va
il est encore 300 mais c'est quand même
deux mois que l'adversaire dans une
position pas cool donc
domination inversée partie complètement
raté
vraiment sans raison
non
en général ça donne des compensations
mais c'est juste vraiment un truc pas
clair quoi ça aurait pu marcher on
aurait crié au génie
non mais je crois que une partie comme
ça récemment dans leur truc sur internet
mais bon
il a eu du jeu toute la partie bon il
est venu à la fin peu importe mais
alors c'est une idée qui arrive ici ou
là quoi mais
en général juste avec les Blancs tu
rentres
dans un truc pas clair on va dire que
les Noirs clairement c'est tout ce qui
souhaitait il est mené au score il te
fait une moderne exprès pour que tu
t'énerves et que et voilà pas assez
typiquement le truc quand je disais
l'autre jour c'est une version pour
jouer pour le bien avec les mains c'est
que tu peux te [ __ ] dans la merde mais
tu peux partir l'adversaire ouais on
dirait
tu t'as juste le drapeau rouge devant le
taureau mais normalement en fait ça
devait pas être un taureau
[Musique]
un match qui a du mal à s'envoler pour
le moment partie un peu raté à la
première de ça nul rapide à la deuxième
là c'est une partie maintenant vraiment
ratée saut pour le moment c'est
logique alors dame D1 ça donne envie de
foudre malheureusement il y a C4
et
c'est 4 ça nasdam d8m
par contre c'est une menace latente dans
la position mais il faut d'abord
s'occuper du roi
s'occuper du roi ou prendre F3 pourquoi
pas parce que c'est encore un pion ça
fait des puntos centraux ça fait que
j'ai 4 va être attaqué ça fait que 4
peut arriver ça fait pas mal de choses
c'est un punto
ça se prend
ça se prend quoi vraiment pas faire ce
serait à 5 aussi
tu vas jamais le faire mais il faut pas
faire quoi
ça reste joli enfin joli
c'est un petit coup comme ça c'est pour
meubler quoi
mais oui juste pion prend F3 et sur dame
prend le 5 dame 6 dames B8 fusée 8
on a tout défendu et on a le prunto qui
part et on a tortan G4 le roi est faible
enfin c'est
terminé
je comprends pas ce genre de partie en
fait
surtout que c'est du Bullet ou du bled
ok mais là en fait il est vraiment un
quart d'heure ça se du temps normalement
pour faire des parties correctes
il a donné la partie là vraiment mais
comme dit étonnant ça serait le scénario
inverse il serait mené au score il va
jouer pour le gain je peux entendre mais
là tu fais nul tu es content quoi
et c'est toi tu es content de faire nul
de nature quoi en fait c'est même pas le
sens du match qui fait que tu vas être
plus content d'habitude tu es juste
content de nul toujours en d'autant plus
quand tu mets un match quoi
mais des fois ils font des trucs
bizarres
enfin c'est dos
3 tu vas menacer des deux ou quatre
enfin
tu vas faire juste eux quatre A4 E3
puis on prend de fin
raison de réfléchir il doit pas trop
comprendre lui-même ce qui se passe
il doit chercher un moyen propre de
finir sans laisser d'arnaque
[Musique]
tout défendu à 4 ok bon il veut essayer
d'ouvrir un peu le jeu pour son fouet
fin
et sur B4 il veut peut-être aller
bouffer carrément assis
[Musique]
après c'est un autre truc bien c'est
quand tu feras genre des coups de tour
ou quoi il y a plus maintenant je suis
quoi
mais en plus il peut avoir un truc sale
genre pion prend A4 ou C4 il menace pas
mais donc du coup
si j'ai envie de te dire en voulant
éviter toutes les merdes et là on voit
la jauge qui remonte
une connerie mais
ouais mais bon
tu sens que contre un ordi il aurait pas
fini il serait déjà fait égaliser en
fait instantanément
toujours avoir
mais même là ça c'est pas trop clair en
fait c'est en train de 4 j'ai
l'impression il devait y avoir un truc
qu'on a pas compris qui lui a dû faire
qui a dû lui faire refuser la vente
parce que eux 3 E2 en fait tu la
laissais tout de suite mat c'était très
bien ça paraissait
8 mais il l'avait d'avant
non mais là vous êtes bizarre
pour finir c'est normal de faire gaffe
mais pas de prendre 5 minutes pour faire
de la merde enfin
non mais c'est vrai mais c'est toujours
pareil ouais c'est prendre du temps pour
faire de la merde si j'avais une bonne
idée de façon et là
tu arrives à une vingt chacun la joueuse
heureuse mais
on voit que c'est pas si simple tout
d'un coup ce qui se passe bah ouais puis
surtout qu'il y a égalité autant et puis
c'est la dynamique d'une partie aussi
c'est qu'en fait tu contrôle plus rien
Wesley il était à deux doigts
d'abandonner enfin je suis sûr qu'il l'a
vu 4 3 c'est sûr qu'il a cru que c'était
gagnant là tout d'un coup ça devient
chaud tu mets le rond ça tu te rends fou
des trois tempos et tout d'un coup et tu
te fais enchaîner les coups la position
elle devient chaude tes Menin zéro tu as
le chat en face de toi qui met des coups
de griffes de partout enfin tu es dans
la merde en fait
tu es vraiment dans la merde on va crier
au génie finalement
non mais ça me fait penser à un combat
celle contre Krilin quoi
tu sais je n'utilisais vraiment que très
peu de ma puissance depuis que j'ai
mangé avec un doigt pour l'instant
18 j'ai beaucoup progressé tu sais
je suis un second doigt
bah non mais c'est enfin c'est terrible
quoi et il 13 20 secondes et c'est dans
la merde tu sais plus quoi jouer tu sues
[Musique]
d'abord
ça c'est le genre de cou qu'est-ce que
ça m'énerve quand j'ai peu de temps
parce que tu sais pas ce qu'il faut que
tu fasses
pourquoi pas et là maintenant il va
faire [ __ ]
c'est bon à quel point on est tout le
temps énervé quand on joue en fait
là tu sais que tu as été con en fait
tu sais que c'est scénario que je
pourrais avoir facilement côté noir
moi aussi enfin c'est de la merde c'est
l'histoire de ma vie en fait mais là tu
sens le Beko
heureusement tu dois avoir un coup de
un coup de fou B7 et sur pousser 5 tu
peux ah mais attention il faut
écarts pour l'instant c'est peut-être
pas si grave ouais mais peut-être tu
fais
[Musique]
bah sinon je passe par là
tu as compris le piège
bah faut jouer et ça va répéter ah c'est
beau ça fait nul mais tu peux pas mais
c'est pas possible non c'est l'autre qui
joue pour le gars mais maintenant B4
gagne regardez la jauge qui s'envole en
plus B4 c'est le coup facile hein
mais B4 c'est hyper facile raté après
facile si tu peux te tromper mais c'est
pas un coup dur
quand même
on crie au génie
la différence de niveau est trop grand
en fait
final de pour le garage en fait d'avoir
craqué le premier dame C7 on peut tous
comprendre parce que
c'est un tellement de
lucidité
tant pis
dans le match là en fait le match est
fini
sans avoir une partie de chiotte
ah ouais mais là c'est enfin c'est dur
ce que tu es déjà mené deux points tu
comptes le mec le plus solide du circuit
tu as rien obtenu avec les Blancs
mais ouais bah ça joue ouais j'ai
l'impression que ça joue un peu mieux en
calife en face de calife que là ça
choque un peu plus tout d'un coup
difficile
la pression
faut pas se
faut pas avoir le hello internet là faut
voir le hello en réel il y a normalement
deux trois classes de différence là on
le voit très bien sur cette partie où se
passe complètement à côté de sa partie
et ça arrive à tout le monde top niveau
pas top niveau et malgré une partie
complètement ratée il réussit à la faire
tourner à gagner
la finale étant huit parties mais bon là
ça peut ça peut aller très vite finir
avant les vitres
ça pourrait bien et on nous montre ce
qu'il a raté bah a priori c'est le dame
C7 qui est le fout un peu dans la sauce
il pouvait pousser les puntos au centre
c'était simple
4 4 il semble que l'idée c'était
vraiment A4 je pense ouais mais trois
j'imagine vas-y
on prend
attention
et sur O2
[Musique]
si c'est ça le main et surtout
je sais même pas si c'était l'idée de
Wesley d'ailleurs non non
histoire de faire un coup qui est pas
dame D1 et puis bon bah à toi quoi
100 points c'est énorme quand je vois
parfois ce que tu
peux perdre gagner sur une belle ou
mauvaise série ouais mais bon enfin
c'est pas la même chose quand tu es top
10 mondial et quand tu débutes quoi
entre guillemets plus tu montes dans la
pyramide plus les points on va le faire
en fait
d'ailleurs les points Fides c'est plus
compliqué enfin ça va plus lentement que
que des points internet ils ont pas la
même manière de compter les points en
fait c'est coefficient 10 alors que sur
Internet coefficient 16 donc c'est
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça c'est toujours
à plus de 3000 sur internet c'est pas
moi
en tout cas la finale on va pas dire
qu'elle est complètement pliée mais
c'était ceux qui étaient favoris là il
fait n'importe quoi il mène quand même
enfin il fait le n'importe quoi sur une
partie la gagne quand même il y a deux
points d'écart il est solide j'ai envie
de dire on suit pour les supporters de
Westland
[Musique]
ça a l'air un peu plié
une finale
comme disait on pressentait quand on a
vu le tableau on avait dit ils sont tous
les forces sont sur la sur le tableau
sur sur le même sur le même moitié de
tableau
et on s'était pas trompé
et on ne s'était pas trompé Fabien
écoute je te propose qu'on fasse une
petite pause j'ai pas à quelle heure à
termine la partie mais on se dit on va
reprendre
c'est ça allez à tout de suite à toute
[Musique]
bonsoir tout le monde
bonsoir
puis de lopost
et du coup on va se diriger vers la
dernière partie du jour en fait
avec Sarine qui va avoir les blancs ça
arrive en sueur enfin complètement ça
suit la grosse goutte
bah moi ça compartiments du jeu perso je
vois pas comment il peut faire tourner
ce match en réalité Fab
à part à moi avant une explosion de
Wesley mais ça me paraît plus dur
d'exploser quand tu as une telle marge
en fait c'est que tu commences à te
détendre à te sérénité à te sérénité
quoi
il le fait son explosion en fait et ça
peut être conséquence donc oui mais je
veux dire que maintenant en fait que tu
as deux points d'avance que tu contrôles
tellement le match faites peut-être que
tu exploses plus du tout enfin c'est
pas connu pour exploser en plein vol
il a explosé hier contre ricaro mais il
a réussi à mettre les barbels et s'en
sortir et aujourd'hui c'est encore mieux
il a explosé mais ça rime qui a contre
explosé
donc ouais je sais pas il faut qu'il
faut qu'il appelle gouver HD quoi ça en
fait
des techniques de résistance quoi
peut-être qu'ils fasses boire du coca ou
du Gange qui va la purifier
ce serait beau qu'il envoie une fiole
une petite fiole pour faire une
dégustation en direct
qui a fait ça d'une région qui a goûté
l'eau alors c'est pas le Gange
[Musique]
la dernière partie de cette première
journée de la finale parce que
évidemment on ne
j'ai perdu j'ai perdu notre j'ai perdu
le mot que je voulais dire on ne boude
pas notre plaisir puisque ça reprend sa
reprend demain Fab ah bah oui quand même
parce que là bon on est pas bien sûr
quand même aujourd'hui de qui est devant
et ça pourrait permettre de faire
tourner les choses demain quoi peut-être
donc on avait dit un Douda mené 4-0 il
est à deux doigts de revenir pourquoi
pas là s'il y a trois
s'ils gagnent la dernière il a encore
une chance 3 ce sera dur mais bon quand
même qui te dit que voilà pourquoi
combien de points
on ne sait pas quoi en réalité
ah ouais
pour le moment ça semble pas avoir
repris
ça s'assure après ça arrive je crois
qu'il prend quand même un petit chèque
de 120 000 balles ça va c'est de la
sueur toute relative
donc au pire du pire c'est cool quand
même
je sais pas trop le coup de la vie en
Inde mais ça doit être bien
tu dois te mettre un petit moment
surtout que tu t'es enfin voilà c'est
tournant internet machin et tout c'est
quand même tranquille
tu cliques un peu hop voilà est-ce que
c'est vraiment une strate de boire pour
déstresser lors de finale à en jeu alors
pas vraiment mais il y a un truc que tu
peux faire qui est connu c'est de mettre
un petit peu d'eau dans ta bouche mais
pas de la boire en fait
de la garder
tu la tourne et c'est censé te calmer un
petit peu
mais
après bon
j'en sais rien à quel point ça marche ou
pas
je vois pas les joueurs de haut niveau
le faire
stratégie chacun fait un peu personne
mais je sais pas moi ce que je fais
quand il y a des quand j'ai pas trop de
temps
et que joue bien ouais non je sais pas
juge je clique en fait je sais pas
vraiment
je pense pas qu'il le fasse
pour éviter le stress je pense pas
uriner dans sa bouteille permettrait
aussi de vider le stress ouais
après je sais pas aux échecs juste tu
calcules non
bon du coup si on ISO
on peut avoir le plan de vlades de faire
fout B6 ful prend cheval
qui avait fait ça contre eux contre
Carlson d'ailleurs tu te rappelles cette
fin de magnifique partie non
-tête la partie 18 tanjukova ou partie
de greative
il a jamais sugalfand
mais en effet sur la chaîne une vidéo
ok on va voir comment il traite ça ouais
là il a quasiment une enfin pas une
balle de match encore mais presque
non mais franchement c'est dur de savoir
enfin je veux dire si t'as vu le DVD tu
sais mais sinon tu sais pas
et donc lui il a pas vu le DVD mais il
s'est quand même donc c'est étonnant
mais farine c'est peut-être pas par
contre non
il va se prendre il va se faire manger
sur case bon ça peut nous faire une
partie
c'est intéressant
il prend un truc
je sais pas trop ce que ça vaut
ça a pas l'air d'être incroyable non
juste échange et tu as plus de pions tu
as plus de pions isolé t'as la paire de
fou mais même juste un fou à 6
pour combien de temps
c'est pas mal déjà faut B2
ça fait un peu penser
c'est vraiment la débandade
difficile pour NiAl non mais sauf une
bonne partie stratégique faut baissez
mis à jouer il faut assise bien jouer
alors c'est pas des coups si dur mais
ils sont ils sont joués à bon escient
bon
non c'est bien joué
ce serait pas mal
une petite nulle pour pour aller vers le
3 Wesley qui pourrait marcher sur sur
cette finale on l'avait stressant hier
quand on suivait les demi-finales qu'il
fallait vraiment se concentrer sur sur
macam Nakamura so on l'avait dit c'était
vraiment les les deux grands favoris et
c'était une demi-finale aux allures de
finale
toute façon les trois meilleurs de la
compétition je pense c'était vraiment de
la caméra duda et so
qui était vraiment dans le dans la même
partie de tableau tous les trois
et qui je pense aurait pu dominer les
cinq autres sans sans grand problème
ah mais ça c'est vraiment hyper égal non
oui
[Musique]
est vraiment vraiment solide
comment tu penses qu'il va continuer la
tour à 8
[Musique]
je ferais nul comment ici Fab
alors bon
donc on parle plutôt de tour Eiffage à 8
mais surtout Raphaël il fait torcer
une idée tu m'aides 5 C4 C5 tu liquide
tout tu regardes en échange mais ça
c'est le truc neutre il y a pas de
raison de faire ça
non bon sinon en fait on joue pour ces 5
dégâts enfin qui ont passé centrale on
le pousse à fond il va nous bloquer et
on reste de tout liquider si on veut
faire comme ça c'est ce qui ce qu'il
veut faire en fait
pour pouvoir doubler et puis c'est 5 et
puis des quatre
après tu peux reprendre du pion ou des
tours et des pièces lourdes pour la
colonne
tu feras E4 pour F4 5 mais ce truc
risqué mais qui va se faire mais bon
on va pas perdre et se faire mater enfin
il y a plus un matériel de ouf et le
pion dépassé va trop être chiant
c'est-à-dire que la dame des trois
pourra pas quitter sinon et
ça devrait partir pour ça en tout cas
difficile pour Wesley de perdre
ici
exploser en plein vol il va avoir plus
de facilité à faire nul qu'il n'aurait à
la perdre celle-là
preuve
j'aime bien enfin je trouve ça logique
ça permet de garder une harmonie dans la
position
ok après tu auras vite c'est aussi ça va
bien
tout va
tout est bon
une partie encore un d'ailleurs
quoi qu'il en soit il y a pas de
position facile à jouer mais c'est pas
des parties spectaculaires là
surtout vu le match vu la tension qui
est quand même largement redescendu
mais ils seront de retour demain les
deux gladiateurs
ils auront eu raison du Fab
manque de pause peut-être pour femme
je suis un peu moins seringue d'habitude
j'ai bien le temps de souffler et là un
peu sur le qui-vive tu sais pas
tu es sur le qui-vive tout le temps
je me suis refait les parties
de l'année dernière c'était autre chose
c'est un beau match ça mais il y a deux
ans par contre
[Musique]
et là bon courage à NiAl pour progresser
dans cette position
parce que là peut-être qu'en fait je me
disais tu peux ne pas faire des quatre
et juste après
encore mieux encore mieux
encore mieux petite nul rapide Fabien
pour clôturer la journée en 12 minutes
de jeu
du coup on aura une belle pause de 21h
jusqu'à la prochaine partie c'est ça et
j'ai envie de dire NiAl qui a peut-être
même dans la tête abandonné toutes
chances de battre de battre Wesley ici
ça va être dur hein quatre parties vont
gagner deux ne pas perdre pour aller
chercher un Armageddon éventuellement
on verra demain comment ça se passe mais
oui très peu de chance pour lui revenir
ouais match match
malheureusement l'écart de niveau entre
les deux hommes et bien trop important
écoutez les amis on se retrouvera demain
pour la suite de ce match je serai très
étonné qu'il échappe que ce global chat
Championship 2022 échappe à Wesley
sceaux mais on n'est jamais à l'abri
d'une d'une surprise dans le sport donc
on se retrouvera demain sur les coups de
18h pour la suite et fin de ce tournoi
merci de d'avoir suivi cette première
journée de de finale avec nous et on
vous retrouve demain ciao ciao